Buonasera a tutti Allora io oggi voglio
parlarvi del rapporto fra pensiero e
linguaggio perché ci dovrebbe
interessare di questo rapporto perché se
non capiamo che cosa condiziona il
nostro pensiero il nostro pensiero non è
libero Allora possiamo metterci la così
Diciamo che il pensiero senza linguaggio
è cieco il linguaggio senza pensiero è
un fantasma è inutile inerte
da come si può capire sto dicendo che il
linguaggio non è un mero strumento di
comunicazione di un pensiero pregresso
preesistente ma è ciò che contribuisce
che aiuta il pensiero a configurare a
descrivere il mondo la realtà Allora vi
invito a fare un piccolo viaggio nel
tempo per me contro il tempo per cercare
di
gettare una luce su questo rapporto
Allora come vedete da questa slide siamo
nell'epoca ovviamente dei nostri
antenati primitivi un luogo ancestrale
inquietante e pericoloso Con una natura
matrigna che ci tende a schiacciare in
cui siamo prede non predatori e però
dobbiamo riuscire a cavarcela inventarci
dei modi per sopravvivere Teniamo
presente che noi non abbiamo il
linguaggio elaborato di corrale verbale
come quello di cui disponiamo ora e
quindi ci espriamo perversi per suoni
gutturali strani Ovviamente questo è un
processo
Ma qui nasce
l'evidenza della caratteristica che
contraddistingue a livello di linguaggio
di esseri umani da tutti gli altri
animali che comunicano in qualche modo
la scrittura in cui dobbiamo intendere
scrittura in un senso ampio più profondo
cioè tutto ciò che è prendere un pezzo
della natura e usarlo come supporto per
scriverci qualche cosa anche un disegno
anche
una uno stilizzazione tutto questo è
scrittura Quindi in senso ampio e lato
questo è creare la cultura cioè lasciare
delle tracce significative del proprio
passaggio in quanto umani e se andiamo a
slie successiva vediamo che
l'esito di questo periodo Paleolitico
così difficile per gli esseri umani è
questa rappresentazione e figurativa e
noi diciamo guarda che bravi questi
primitivi che erano bravi anche a fare
delle pitture No non è così perché
questo non è uno specchio della realtà
una rappresentazione di qualche cosa che
esiste già questo lo diciamo noi ma se
ci mettiamo nel loro tempo nel loro
epoca Questo è uno specchio per la
realtà è come un libro del mondo da
leggere per poi imparare ad abitare il
mondo fuori un mondo di secondo livello
Grazie al quale io so come mi devo
comportare e quindi il primo uomo la
prima donna che ha fatto questo contorno
di questa figura ha creato quella figura
cioè la resa disponibile alla vista di
se stesso e degli altri che dopo quando
sono uscite hanno iniziato a vedere il
mondo configurato in questo modo perché
per fare quel bordo lì che è un concetto
anche matematico molto complesso
bisogna rappresentare i suoi due
dimensioni qualche cosa che noi
esperiamo nella realtà su tre dimensioni
in continuo movimento poi con tutto il
carico emotivo di questa bestia informe
per noi che ci arriva addosso Quindi
questo è un grande passaggio si crea
l'oggettività in cui io vedo da fuori il
mondo e inizio a conoscerlo davvero poi
arrivano degli altri che fanno i
disegnini quelli con le frecce E allora
diciamo a guardano e siamo questi qui e
Allora vedete che si crea anche la
soggettività Nel senso che riusciamo a
oggettivare anche noi stessi e nascere
autocoscienza qui Siamo invece in
un'altra epoca quella della cultura
orale
in cui la parola è molto pregna di
significativo di significato è molto
sviluppata una parola mitica delle
tradizioni
appunto fondative fondamentali quindi è
però bisogna trovare un supporto meno
per ituro e mortale di quello del corpo
umano perché bisogna che queste questi
nostri saperi vengono tramandati E
allora come si fa
una strada è quella degli ideogrammi
cioè prendo le parole e le trasferisco
su supporto segni con una scrittura un
singolo segno per ciascuna parola
molto divertente peraltro molto creativo
questo tipo di linguaggio perché per
dire per il linguaggio scritto perché se
io voglio dire in cinese i due grandi
antichi una tazza che brilla disegno una
stilizzazione della tazza e ci mette un
solo una luna Il problema che è molto
complesso perché se io ho tantissime
parole devo avere tantissimi segni
corrispondenti e ricordarmi anche
l'associazione quindi ci vuole un
professionista uno scriba uno scrivano e
non è molto Democratica questa lingua
non è molto ergonomica perché non
permette a tutti di comprenderla E
impararla più o meno facilmente e quindi
c'è tutta un'altra strategia
che ci permette di fare questo che
quella della trascrizione fonetica
e vedete come in uno spartito musicale
trasferisce i suoni e li rende segni
Qual è il fatto uno dice Beh ma allora
ancora peggio Scusami devi ogni parola
cioè tutti i suoi se la dividi in suoni
e dopo trasferisci i suoni di là ma sono
ancora di più No perché i suoni
ritornano o i cosx Nomos sono italiano
casarco cane gli stessi suoni ritornano
combinati in modo diverso nel flusso
fonetico della nostra parlata e quindi
cosa fanno i Greci che Reggiano questa
strategia dei Fenici a Giuliano Cicci le
vocali
fanno proprio questa associazione fra
singolo suono in cui scompongo ogni
parola e corrispettivo segno in questo
modo in 25 segnetti io ho risolto il
problema però Attenzione che qui c'è una
proprio una soglia dell'umano
incredibile Perché il linguaggio cambia
la nostra mente Perché cosa succede
succede che
questa parola vivente perde il suo corpo
che viene trasferito Su un supporto
aimmateriale viene scomposta la parola
Perché i singoli suoni non hanno senso
e anche i singoli segni che li
rappresentano non hanno senso il senso
il significato riappare Quando io leggo
le letterine le metto insieme e mi
ritorna il mio significato solo che non
è più sul corpo vivente della persona
che mi racconta il mito e che connette
le parole tra di loro è su un corpo
separato e quindi io vedo il significato
pura come se avessi lo spirito
disincarnato e allora poi questo è un
sistema chiuso autoreferenziale perché
col condizionale Noi abbiamo tutte le
paroline che sono spiegate dalle altre È
la pura astrazione più totale Una
macchina strativa il primo algoritmo la
prima intelligenza artificiale
effettivamente che se noi non guardiamo
bene ci può anche ingannare però se noi
la guardiamo bene può essere uno
strumento potentissimo che permette a
Platone di dire No guarda questo
esemplare di cavallo Perché Perché
L'ideale è la parola
il concetto a sé stante di cui il
concreto è una materializzazione quindi
l'astratto diventa dominante sul
concreto Socrate va in giro molestia
dicendo che cos'è il coraggio e quelli
dicono Beh Ettore coraggioso vi dice no
no no io non ti ho chiesto di dirmi un
esempio incarnato di un personaggio
coraggioso ti ho chiesto Tom la cosa in
sé Che cos'è il coraggio
e questi Ovviamente poi lo ammazzano che
dicono cosa vuole questo
però questo dà inizio a una grande
avventura del pensiero umano Ma la mente
logica così orientata analitica che
spezza ricompone
È connaturata l'essere umano 1921
andiamo in
[Musica]
nelle campagne uzbekie dove c'è tra
Alexander Lauria che sta facendo degli
esperimenti che vuole capire appunto se
i contadini analfabeti capiscono e
sillogismo aristotelico oppure no Allora
prova dice allora tutti gli orsi in
Siberia sono bianchi Io incontro un orso
in Siberia Di che colore L'orso
ovviamente bianco questo maggiore minore
conclusione e Questi dicono Ah ma cosa
chiedi a me che non sono mai stato in
Siberia B Ma sarà nero e quell'altro
diciamo nome nero Eh sì perché io ho
visto solo orsi neri quindi
probabilmente è nero che ne so arriva un
altro che dice no sono sicuramente
bianchi e lui le Diciamo finalmente una
intelligente questo era stato
alfabetizzato perché è in corso Appunto
una campagna di serviziotazione abbiamo
imparato a leggere e scrivere non è che
i contadini analfabeti siano stupidi Non
sono affatto stupidi ragionano benissimo
forse anche meglio di noi dal punto di
vista pragmatico che basano tutto sulla
loro esperienza
prossima slide e arriviamo torniamo
indietro e arriviamo ai nostri
Greci anche qui grande trasformazione
l'incontro fra la matematica e la logica
perché perché la matematica che precede
la logica greca ovviamente
nell'incontro con questo con la
geometria euclidee Al di là degli
assiomi ha un'introduzione clamorosa
perché Euclide dice parla di linea senza
spessore ora voi Provate a tracciare una
linea c'è lo spessore Ma questo concetto
puramente astratto permette di calcolare
le superfici se c'è lo spessore diventa
un volume e il gioco non funziona e
questo è un inizio della matematica
occidentale e mondiale
non solo scienze moderne 1600 Galileo
moto
rettilineo uniforme un'assurdità in
senso fisico perché non lo troverai mai
un concetto asintotico all'infinito
grazie al confronto con il quale però io
posso Galileo imparare a rendere
intreggibili tutti i movimenti che
esistano prossima slide abbiamo un'altra
situazione e siamo ai giorni nostri che
cosa succede qui codice di letterine
alfabetiche e questa è il codice
genetico del nostro DNA che cosa succede
qua che queste lentine che sono i nostri
linguaggi che comunque potenziano la
nostra vista ma sono uno strumento
creato da noi se noi ci dimentichiamo
che esistono e ci paiono trasparenti ci
dimentichiamo
proiettano le loro caratteristiche
sull'oggetto della nostra conoscenza e
noi pensiamo di vedere sempre solo la
realtà così com'è dimenticandoci delle
interfaccia questa possibile pericolo
che si intravede qui è confermato da
alcuni matematici che stanno contestando
questo approccio dicendo guardate voi
state applicando la matematica del
distretto
analitica quei codici che racchiude
tutto in se stessa ha un continuum
biologico invece in cui tu hai la
singolarità e la storicità di ogni
organismo per cui non puoi rinchiudere
uno schema di questo tipo tra resto
Darwin diceva che l'evoluzione è appunto
riproduzione variazione selezione Ma
andiamo ancora oltre l'ultimo step
l'intelligenza artificiale grandissima
innovazione umana attuale Ma se noi poi
la facciamo unità misura della nostra
intelligenza in questa riduzionismo
clamorosa e diciamo che quindi noi siamo
più stupidi dei computer perché
effettivamente loro come calcolo come
mente analitica
hanno più potenza e più velocità anche
qui non ci stiamo dimenticando le nostre
lenti
Ma se andiamo soprattutto alla radice
Chi è che ha inventato matematicamente
che ha messo le basi per hardware
software e
calcolo computazionale Alan turing
che ha detto attenzione che la mia
macchina analitiche sono un'imitazione
una scimmiottamento della capacità
deduttiva umana non sono
un modello matematico
Allora che cosa succede che noi dobbiamo
stare attenti a questa magia alfabetica
che ha un doppio significato una potenza
incredibile che grazie all'astratto ci
permette di conoscere il mondo in modi
impensabili ma anche in senso negativo
Cioè che diventa una superstizione
Allora c'è questo pericolo da guardare
Ma perché io ho raccontato tutto questo
perché noi non siamo le nostre idee Noi
siamo intelligenza siamo creatività
siamo empatia cioè sentire intuire che
cosa prova un altro e in tutto questo
quindi possiamo ben distinguere le
nostre idee dalle persone se io credo
empatia con una persona posso scontrarmi
sulle idee perché questo modo di
rispettarla Mal che vada ho torto imparo
qualcosa poi se avevo ragione insegno
qualcosa poi Magari scopro che avevamo
tolto tutte e due e impariamo e
insegniamo tutte e due in un colpo solo
e Magari capiamo che dobbiamo trovare
una nuova incrocio una nuova fonte di
una nuova tipologia di conoscenza
e quindi bisogna andare a cercare ciò
che smentisce le nostre idee non ciò che
le conferma a quello ci pensa
l'algoritmo dei social media che ci
ripropone sempre quello che abbiamo
cercato il giorno prima e quindi una
unità in progress come dice bene il
nostro titolo in progress vuol dire in
avanzamento ma vuol dire anche in corso
d'opera c'è un'umanità che sa Anche
guardarsi indietro controllare i propri
passi e dire ma forse abbiamo sbagliato
qualcosa forse dobbiamo cambiare
direzione idea quindi bisogna unire le
forze e unire gli sguardi Quindi anche i
nostri primitivi che noi riteniamo
insomma Dei degli ingenuati in fondo
hanno qualcosa da insegnarci perché
quando si mettevano intorno al fuoco in
cerchio lo facevano perché ciascuno
potesse scaldarsi E poi perché così
ciascuno guardava le spalle degli altri
e lo poteva avvisare di un pericolo e
quindi avevano uno sguardo unico
collettivo quindi insomma unire le forze
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]